I'm gonna struggle to the day I die of
allowing yourself to look at glass
half-empty I just feel like I feel like
and now I understand its DNA and its
wiring and if you grow up with a mother
who's extremely negative it's a really
tough situation to break out of it just
proven I've understood you grew up in a
tough town I get it
there's a couple of issues with that
number one
everybody's got stuff the problem is
nobody cares once you understand that
nobody cares and you're complaining to
empty air do you start going in a little
bit of a different direction and yeah I
mean I try to I like putting out
positivity the small minority of people
that are mad and angry and hateful and
dark are much louder than the big
percentage of us that are happy and
excited and feel great and because the
way technology works they are much
louder than they've ever been before
and so I feel like as somebody who's got
full of bright light and happiness that
I need to start getting louder about
that as well because that's the only way
we're going to come back
[Applause]
if that's the thing that's going to get
the cloud as clap so far from this
conversation that's what we need to be
focusing on
I feel more responsibility than ever as
somebody who is happy and wants other
people to be happy
genuine if you leave anything for any of
us please take on the sense of
responsibility that if you've got good
and you feel good to start sharing that
content as well because the world needs
more of it
[Music]